le télétravail c'est une formule dont on
parle depuis plusieurs décennies on
n'invente pas ça ce soir mais ça semble
quand même être une réelle tendance pour
bien des canadiens
près du quart des gens en emploi affirme
avoir fait du télétravail selon
statistique canada
marianne plamondon est avocate associée
au cabinet langlois avocat à montréal
bonsoir êtes spécialisé justement dans
le droit de l'emploi du travail
présidente sortante de l'ordre des
conseillers en ressources humaines
agréés est ce que vous constatez que le
télétravail est voulue et souhaitée est
une tendance de plus en plus les
entreprises se dotent de politique de
façon encore drilles télétravail de
façon à ce que ce soit sécurité avec ça
respecte les lois qui sont applicables à
ce type d'emploi l'ompi comme tel y'a
pas de dispositions dans la loi mais
chose certaine les employeurs doivent
s'assurer que le milieu de travail à la
maison est aussi sécuritaire qu'au
travail mais c'est aussi en fait de il
ya tellement de bénéfices pour les
employeurs on pense notamment à la
diminution des coûts locatifs pour une
entreprise où j'ai agi pour faire un
programme de télétravail
ils ont réussi à réduire d'un tiers lors
leurs espaces locatifs étant donné que
les employés passés maîtres la quatre
jours à la maison et une seule journée à
la au travail et l'ont créée en fait un
espace qui partage et qu'on appelle les
espaces collaboratifs de façon à ce
qu'il y ait de l'échangé entre les
bureaux et ça permet évidemment de
diminuer les coûts de l'employeur ça
augmente aussi la productivité parce que
les employés n'ont pas de distraction à
la maison ils peuvent plus se concentrer
et s'est vu aussi comme étant une
tactique pour accroître l'attractivité
de l'entreprise
parce qu'évidemment ça permet à des
employés qui demandent plus loin de
pouvoir postuler sur des emplois donc il
ya clairement des avantages mais est ce
que c'est une tendance est ce que c'est
de plus en plus utilisée est ce qu'on
est en avance aucun des ce qu'on est
encore à l'heure actuelle avec ses sur
l' annonce que le rem va fermer le
tunnel du mont royal va fermer en vrais
gens m'ont extrêmement a discuté par les
employeurs certains en pleurs ont même
pris des bureaux périphériques à laval
ou sur la rive-sud de façon à permettre
à leurs employés de travailler de façon
périphérique parce que des employés qui
ne pourront pas se rendre au travail ce
jour au lendemain et veut pas avec les
problématiques de circulation les
employeurs prennent conscience de la le
cac et perdu dans les transports le
stress que cela engendre sur l'employé
et surtout dans certains types d'emplois
il n'y a pas vraiment de 2,2 des packs
négatif parce que si on parle d'un
emploi ou c'est du travail intellectuel
qui demande de l'analyse et de la
concentration
souvent l'employé qui vont rester à la
maison va être moins dérangé il va donc
réussir plus facilement atteindre les
objectifs
cela dit est ce que quand même des
inconvénients est ce qu'on est est ce
qu'un point et danger de perte de
productivité et même en guise de fraudes
c'est à dire d'employés qui
n'exerceraient pas nécessairement les
heures pour lesquelles ces gens là sont
payés pour ça qu'il faut encadrer en
fait en mettant un contrat de dans
lequel on planifie le télétravail
comment il va se faire piller en créant
des engagements pour l'emploi ni
exactement où est ce qu'on va demander à
l'employé parfait vous avez le droit
travailler de la maison mais maintenant
voici les obligations qui vous incombent
et vous vous engagez à les respecter
notamment de ne pas avoir de personnes à
charge à la maison et qui peuvent
déranger le travail par exemple
oui bah oui évidemment ou encore
s'assurer que la personne va pouvoir
être joignable durant les heures
régulières de travail en tout temps ce
genre d'engagement là on voit ça mais
c'est sûr que les les employeurs qui
mettent en place ces outils là on le
bénéfice mais les principales choses qui
en fait freine les employeurs à le faire
souvent c'est l'évaluation de rendement
la capacité d'évaluer la performance de
l'employé d'où le fait que pour les
emplois qui sont fondés sur des
objectifs ou des résultats c'est plus
facile d'aller vers un système de
télétravail mais aussi l'enjeu qui
souvent soulevée par les employeurs
c'est la question de l'engagement au
travail de la cohésion de l'équipe de
l'esprit d'équipé parce qu'ils se disent
mais les gens n'ont pas l'occasion
autant d'échangés de collaborer comme
le milieu de travail mais maintenant les
outils pas quand même ou de nos jours
les outils numériques permettent quand
même de créer d'autres façons d'avoir
cette cohésion l'heure mais faut faire
attention aussi quand on fait du
télétravail à ne pas dépasser une
certaine ligne qui pourraient une
intrusion de la part des employeurs dans
la vie privée des employés des
travailleurs à la maison ou dans des
espaces de cotravail tout à fait et un
employé a toujours le droit de refuser
d'entrer dans un système de télétravail
maintenant à partir du moment qu'il le
fait ils doivent le faire de façon
honnête on sait que tous les employés à
une obligation d'honnêteté de loyauté et
c'est sûr qu'un employeur pourrait
vouloir surveiller l'utilisation des
systèmes technologiques par exemple
durant les heures de travail
si la personne est à la maison encore là
il faut qu il ya des motifs raisonnables
pour penser qu'il ya eu de la fraude
pour vérifier ces systèmes la ya
beaucoup d'informations sensibles des
documents confidentiels comment on
s'assure la protection des documents
confidentiels dans le cadre du
télétravail et dans le cadre des
politiques on va mettre en place
on va donner de l'équipement pour
s'assurer que la personne puisse mettre
sous clé lorsqu'il à l'extérieur des
heures normales de travail les documents
en question ou qui est une stratégie
pour s'assurer que ces documents ne
reste pas à la maison et soient
accessibles par les autres membres de la
famille notamment mais également aussi
on va s'assurer ainsi que le milieu de
travail répondent ou aux critères de
sécurité en vertu de la loi sur la santé
sécurité au travail par exemple
donc c'est très bien merci beaucoup
marianne clément dont très intéressant
de regarder cette perspective est cette
prospective
merci merci merci bien